he was one of the biggest r b recording
artists of a generation
now r kelly faces spending the rest of
his life in jail after being found
guilty on all counts at a trial in new
york
today's guilty verdict forever brands r
kelly as a predator
who used his fame and fortune to prey
on the young
the vulnerable and the voiceless for his
own sexual gratification
the attorney who represented many metoo
survivors says kelly is the worst abuser
of them all
today r kelly
has been convicted of very serious
federal crimes
mr kelly
who once described himself as a quote
genius end quote to one of my clients
who testified
is nothing but a convicted felon
the 54 year old singer had faced
accusations of sexual assault against
young women and children for decades but
seemed almost untouchable the music
industry and the media now stand accused
of turning a blind eye to allegations
made against him for far too long i
would say that he was definitely
protected the boys and girls that he did
you know sail and rape and i would say
because he was protected by
not only right
everybody around him producers the music
industry itself everyone knew this was
going on and they protected him so it
didn't stop it increased
r kelly will be sentenced next may and
faces decades behind bars
victoria gatenbee al jazeera